bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo alors j'ai plein
d'énergie ou l'art parce que là les
vacances sont presque finis donc on a
vraiment rechargé les batteries mais
même pendant les vacances le prof de
sciences sociales restent un prof de
sciences sociales et les réflexes sont
toujours présents et je trouvais ça
intéressant de vous partager ce que j'ai
vu sur twitter
figurez vous que sur twitter de mon fils
twitter je suis tombé sur une image je
me suis dit ça c'est un film j'ai
vérifié et savez vous quoi à bien cette
info alors dans cette vidéo je vous
montrer comment vérifier mais tout de
suite le générique génériques
vous
[Musique]
vidéo s'adresse à la fois aux élèves qui
doivent pratiquer jour après jour la
critique des sources au cours de
sciences sociales mais aussi dans tous
les cours je sais quand vous bassine
avec ça mais c'est tellement important
les professeurs aussi peuvent être
intéressés par cette vidéo parce que
dans cette vidéo je vais montrer
concrètement comment on peut faire et
donc c'est un savoir faire et un outil
qu'ils pourront aussi transmettre à
leurs élèves enfin je pense que chaque
citoyen chaque personne va maintenant on
doit quand même avoir un certain esprit
critique par rapport à tous les messages
qui nous inondent et donc c'est toujours
intéressant de se poser des questions
sur l'information et sur sa véracité
alors l'image que j'ai vu c'est celle ci
on a quelqu'un sur twitter qui remet un
peu en question la politique migratoire
italienne alors si vous voulez connaître
mon avis mais ce n'est pas l'objet de la
vidéo je ne dois pas donner mon avis
donc je ne donnerai pas je suis assez
favorable à une remise en question de la
politique migratoire italienne est donc
le problème le problème c'est que ben
voyons en voyant le tweet moi je me suis
dis bah tiens y'a pas de source j'avais
un a priori positif par rapport à cette
photo par rapport à ce message je me
suis dit tiens je vais le partager sur
la page facebook de la société pour que
les élèves à la rentrée baliser une
ressource sur laquelle on peut commencer
à discuter sur l'immigration voyez
lorsque des peuples qui ont émigré dans
le passé sont aujourd'hui des peuples
qui accueille les immigrés donc je
trouvais ça intéressant sauf qu'il n'y
avait pas de source et apa de source
sûre cette photo alors je me suis dit
méfions nous de cette photo et j'ai fait
ce que je vais vous montrer ici à
l'écran j'ai été recherché le la comment
dire l'adresse de la photo vous savez
que chaque photo sur internet
et bien elle a une adresse la page sur
laquelle vous consultez la photo à une
adresse mais la photo elle-même à une
adresse donc il faut cliquer sur la
photo
pour retrouver le lien de cette photo il
y en a beaucoup ils savent le faire mais
pour ce qu'il n'était pas au courant de
ça mais voilà maintenant ils le sont
avec ce lien vous fait un copié collé
sur un ordinateur c'est assez facile
contrôle c pour copier compte relever
pour coller le lien et je vais dans
l'onglet qui est là bas en haut à droite
sur mon écran goût
je sélectionne images et là j'ai un
moteur de recherche qui va rechercher
les images grâce aux liens de sel je
fais un compte relever dans google et
quand je tape sur enter vous voyez ce
qui apparaît c'est pas du tout une image
qui concerne l'immigration italienne
c'est une image qui concernait le retour
des troupes américaines au pays selon
alors ce qui est dingue dans cette
histoire enfin un petit peu interpellant
pour le prof de sciences sociales ou
c'est que j'ai retrouvé cette image
plusieurs fois sur le net partagé
repartager bien sûr ce 8 heures mais
j'ai retrouvé sur facebook un don parmi
mes contacts
il y avait des personnes qui l'ont
partagée aussi alors que c'était un fait
alors j'en entends certains d'entre vous
qui vont dire surtout les plus grincheux
les vieux jeux qui vont me dire ah oui
mais ça voilà ça c'est internet vous
voyez ça internet internet sanekh des
erreurs et tout ça tue pas d'accord
parce que sur twitter si on lit les
commentaires du tweet original et bien
on va se rendre compte que les personnes
qui suivaient le fil
elles ont repéré le fric et elles l'ont
dénoncé assez vite
bien avant que je ne trouve moi même
donc si j'avais été directement dans les
commentaires j'aurais tout de suite vu
que c'était un flic vous voyez sur
facebook ou sur twitter ou sur n'importe
quel réseau social et sur internet de
manière plus générale en effet on peut
partager n'importe quoi mais aussi
beaucoup plus de personnes qui peuvent
être vigilante et qu'ils vont relever
les fait qu'internet c'est bien pour
trouver des informations parfois on
trouve n'importe quoi mais on trouve
aussi des moyens pour tester et
contrôler la véracité de l'information
et voilà j'espère que je vous ai
communiqué de l'énergie via cette vidéo
en tout cas moi j'en ai plein je suis
très impatient de reprendre la rentrée
mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec lui
surtout de faire de la critique des
sources et de dire que ça c'est pas
pertinent que ça ça du n'importe quoi eh
bien tout ça on va recommencer
évidemment en classe de sciences
sociales mais moi je vous invite même si
vous n'êtes pas dans ma cage aux
sciences sociales bompas à venir dans ma
case du genre social sinon les élèves et
et mes collègues vont pas être d'accord
que tout le monde vienne dans la case du
lien social une fou mais regardez la
société
regardez la vidéo où j'ai déjà fait sur
l'acquis très critique des sources et ne
soyez pas des moutons non s'il vous
plaît donc voilà vous avez un outil en
plus je vous souhaite une bonne cote
nation dans toutes vos activités quelles
qu'elles soient et à très bientôt
[Musique]
vous